رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان مما سماه مؤامره وجوديه تهدد
السودان ودعا كل من يستطيع حمل السلاح
للقتال ضد من وصفهم بالمتمردين تاتي هذه
الدعوه في ظل ارتفاع حده المواجهات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع في الخرطوم وولايات
اخرى مؤخرا وتعليقي مفاوضات جده بين
الجانبين ورفض مجلس السياده مبادرات
افريقيه لحل الازمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله دعوه البرهان
المواطنين للانخراط في القتال ضد الدعم
السريع في هذه المرحله من الصراع وما
وجاهه السياق الذي وضعها البرهان فيه
كذلك ما هي المتغيرات التي يمكن ان تترتب
على هذه الدعوه على الصراع بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في الخرطوم
ومنعكاساتها المحتمله على الاوضاع في بقيه
اجزاء البلاد
واخيرا ما هي المسارات التي يمكن ان
تاخذها الاوضاع في السودان في ظل تصاعدي
حده الصراع وانسداد افق الحوار في جده
ورفض مبادرات الحل الافريقيه
[موسيقى]
في ظل خروقات في صباح يوم عيد الاضحى
لهدنتين اعلانهما بشكل منفصل طرف الصراع
في السودان الجيش والدعم السريع ومع
انسداد افق الحوار بين الجانبين بعد تعليق
مفاوضات جده ورفض مجلس السياده السوداني
مبادره الايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي وبعد
نحو شهر من دعوه وزاره الدفاع السودانيه
المتقاعدين العسكريين للالتحاق بالجيش وسع
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
الدعوه لحمل السلاح لتشمل كل قادر على
حمله ضد ما سماه مؤامره وجوديه تستهدف
البلاد
شعب السوداني لابي ان حجم المؤامره يتطلب
من الجميع ان يغيظ والاستعداد للتصدي
للمهددات الوجوديه لدولتنا لذلك نطلب من
جميع شباب بلادي وكل من يستطيع الدفاع ان
لا يتردد او يتاخر بان يقوم بهذا الدور
الوطني في مكان سكنه او بالانضمام للحياه
العسكريه
لنيل شرف الدفاع عن بقاء الدوله السودانيه
التي تداعد عليها المؤامرات داخليا
وخارجيا
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم
حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن
الدوحه مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومن باريس محمد تورشين الكاتب
والباحث السياسي السوداني اهلا بكم جميعا
في مواء الخبر وابدا معك استاذ مزمل ابو
القاسم ما الذي استجد بعد اكثر من سبعين
يوما من الحرب ليجعل رئيس مجلس السياده
يدعو كل من يستطيع حمل السلاح ان يحمله
في البدايه احييك واحيي ضيفك اقول اننا
كمعظم السودانيين كنا نتوهم في بدايه
الامر ان هذا
هذه الاحداث مجرد محاوله
لاستيلاستيلاء على السلطه بانقلاب مسلح مع
مرور الايام اتضح ان هذا الامر
ومشكل مؤامره تشارك فيها اطراف دوليه
واقليميه تستهدف اختطاف الدوله السودانيه
واجراء تغيير ديموغرافي كبير فيها
الحرب الدعم السريع لم تقتصر على الجيش بل
توجهت في الاساس الى المواطنين
بالاستيلاء على المنازل احتلال الاحياء
السكنيه احترى المستشفيات النهب والسلب
النهب تقريبا البنيات الاساسيه نهب البنوك
المؤسسات العامه والخاصه الاعتقال
العشوائي الخطف القتل لم يتركوا
ولا انتهاكا الا فعلوه وذلك ادى الى
ارتفاع واين الجيش من كل ما يجري اذا على
الارض الجيش ذكر مرارا وتكرارا انه ان يده
مغلوله لانه لا يستطيع ان يهاجم قوات
الدعم السريع في المنازل هم يحتمون
بالمنازل يحتمون بالمستشفيات يحتمون
بالجامعات وبالمدارس وبالكنائس حتى حتى
دور العباده لم تسلم من شرورهم
على المنازل يعني
اكثر من الطريق من منشاه عسكريه اكثر من
مركز يمكن اذا اراد الجيش فعلا
ان يواجههم فيها يستطيع
ايضا الدعم السريع يسيطر على منازل
المدنيين طرد السكان من المنازل ونهبها
وسرقها وتعدى عليها ايضا يسيطر على
المستشفيات واريد ان يسيطر
الكلمه لحافظ كبير واسالك عن نظره كيف
ينظر الدعم السريع لدعوه البرهان بالامس
تحيه طيبه لكم وكل عام وانتم بخير وكذلك
التحيه الى ضيوفك الكرام انا اعتقد ان هذه
الدعوه التي يعني قدمها رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد الجيشيه اعتراف صريح منه بالفشل
العسكري وكذلك الفشل السياسي من جعل هذه
المعركه من كونها معركه للقوات المسلحه من
اجل انهاء ما اعتبره تمرد الى الهروب
للامام ومحاوله اعتبار هذه معركه وجوديه
وهذا كله لا يتسق والواقع كان في البدايه
الامر اعتقد الذين يناصرون هذه الرؤيا ان
هناك تمرد عسكري جزء من المكون العسكري
تمرد على المؤسسه الام لكن كل مره نتفاجا
بان هناك يعني تحليلات او هناك هروب من
الحقيقه نحو ادعات لا تصمت كثيرا سرعان ما
يتركها الذين تبنوها في البدايه للبحث عن
معركه اخرى وهذا الاتجاه هو اتجاه خطير
يقود او يعني يجعل المعركه من كونها معركه
بين مؤسستين عسكريتين نظاميتين الى معركه
الكون ضد الكل وهذا الطريق هو طريق الحرب
الاهليه ان تجعل السلاح في يد كل من
يستطيع حمله سلاح نحن يعني سبق البرهان
الى هذا الامر حاكم اقليم دارفور عندما
يعني دعا الناس الى حمل السلاح هذا الامر
لم يحقق امنا في دارفور فمنذ ان اعلن ذلك
سقطت اكثر من مدينه وكذلك راينا الفوضى في
مدينه الجنينه يعني هذا الاتجاه اتجاه خطر
جدا
هذا اعلان صريح من البرهان بالتخلي عن
مسؤولياته كقائد للجيش
واعلان فشله في قياده اي عمليه عسكريه
تقود الى انهاء ما اعتبره تمرد وبالتالي
كانت
هذا اليوم
ليعلق على هذا يعني في حال فعلا كانت هناك
مؤامره وجوديه نستطيع ان نفهم هذا ما قاله
البرهان هل ترى فعلا ان هناك مؤامره
وجوديه وما مؤشراتها ان وجدت
في البدء التحيه لك وكذلك لضيوفك الكرام
والساده المشاهدين الاقارب وكل عام وانتم
بخير انا في تقديري هذه التصريحات التي
خرجت من عبد الفتاح البرهان بالامس هي
نستطيع ان نقول بانها فيها جانب اعلامي
بمحاوله اداره الموقف وارسال رسائل في
بريد الجميع بعد البرهان هو ماذا يسيطر
على مقاليد الامور العسكريه وكذلك
السياسيه فضلا عن ذلك عندما اشار الى ان
هنالك مؤامره كان ينبغي ان يتحدث بشكل
مباشر وبالشكل صريح وان يقوم باجراءات
دبلوماسيه بما في ذلك قطع العلاقات ما هذه
الدول التي تدير المؤامره فنحن نعلم ان
هنالك بعض التقارير التي تتحدث بان هنالك
جهات تتواضع وتتامر على السودان من جهال
اقليميه لديها مصالح او كذلك الجهات
الدوليه معلومه ان في السياسه الدوليه كل
دوله تضع الى تحقيق وكذلك لا تقتصر هذه
الدعوه تحقيق المصالح فقط بالتدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه وانما حتى بتغيير الانظمه
الحاكمه وهذا امر ومعلومه ومعروف في
السياسه الدوليه والسودان ليس استثناء
فبالتالي اذا كان الامر هكذا ولا بلا شك
ان القران هو رئيس مجلس السياده والقائد
العام للجيش ولديه معلومات مخابراتيه
واستخباراتها فكان ينبغي ان يكون اكثر
الجراه واكثر شجاعه ويتحدث بان الدوله
الفلاني التي تسعى بشكل مباشر لتغويت
واحداث تغييرات جذريه في الدوله السودانيه
لذا قررنا قطع علاقات معها كذلك ان يسمي
الاشياء باسمائها بان هنالك دول المتورثه
وتدعم هذه الحرب التي تجري بين الجيش
الدعم السريع تدعم الدعم السريع ومقاتلين
اجانب ليسوا سودانيه فنحن نعلم ان الدعم
السريع بها عناصر غير سودانيه لكن هذه
العناصر كانت موجوده وبيان البرهان وبين
كل القيادات السياسيه فبالتالي انا في
تقدير هذه الحرب الان بدات تخرج شيئا
يتوقع بانه سيحسمها في الاوقات وجيزه في
ساعات وجيزه لكن الان اتسع نطاق بشكل كبير
جدا البرهان اختار ان لا يسمي اي طرف كما
ذكرت هو اختار ان يكتفي سيد مزمل ابو
القاسم بالدعوه لحمل السلاح رغم ان هناك
دعوه مشابهه حصلت قبل شهر من وزير الدفاع
بالتحديد تجاه المتقاعدين العسكريين لماذا
تختلف النتيجه هذه المره
الان لهذه الدعوه التي اطلقها بالامس تمت
الاستجابه من عشرات الالاف من
المعاشير القوات المسلحه انتظموا في
الحاميات العسكريه وهذه الدعوه دون مستوى
الطموح لان هذه الانتهاكات الذين نتحدث
عنها لم تاتي من الجيش ولا من وسائل
الاعلام محليه اتت من مؤسسات دوليه
التدمير الخارجيه الامريكيه اتت من
البرلمان الاوروبي اتت من المفوض السامي
لحقوق الانسان في جنيف اليوم المبعوثه
الاممي فولكر
حمى القوات الدعم السريع مسؤوليه
الانتهاكات التي تحدث ضد المدنيين والعنف
والاقتصاد الاقتصاد والقتل والامر الذي
ربما ايضا اقر به الدعم السريع قبل يومين
فقط سمعنا حماتي يقول ان هناك لجنه ستتكون
لمحاسمه مرتكبيها ولكن فقط اسمح لي
طبعا كان ذلك موجه للطرفين اريد ان اشير
الى ما نقلته عن مصادر عسك السيد مزمل
الالاف من عناصر المخابرات البشير ذوي
الصله بالحركه الاسلاميه يقاتلون مع الجيش
ضد الدعم السريع
ونقلت كذلك ان نحو سته الاف عنصر من
المخابرات انضموا للجيش قبل اسابيع من بدء
القتال طبعا هناك مسؤول في الجيش السوداني
حسب
قال ان الجيش مؤسسه محترفه وليس له علاقه
باي حزب سياسي او ايديولوجي ما تعليقك
الجيش دعا المعاشيين
للانخراط في صفوفه وهؤلاء قد يكون لهم
لبعضهم علاقه بنظام البشير او بغيره المهم
في الامر ان الدعوه لم تعطي على اساس
سياسي هذه الدعوه تخص كل سوداني نحن نتحدث
عن محاوله لاختطاف الدوله السودانيه ظلت
قوات الدعم السريع تحاول انكار الاتهامات
المنسوبه اليها والانتهاكات التي
القتال هذا ما تقوله
لا هذا الامر انا لا علم لي به ولا اعتقد
انه حصل لان هذه الحظ لمها الجيش هذه
الحرب خططت الدعم السريع منذ سنوات وهو
الذي
بداها يوم 13
بمحاصره مطار مروي وبمحاصره
وانتقل لحفظ كبير تكرر الحديث عن انتهاكات
ارتكبها دعم السريع وكما قلنا اعترف بها
الدعم السريع الى اي حد الحديث عن هذه
الامتحان في حديث البرهان يمكن ان يشجع
المواطنين على حمل السلاح
وبطبيعه الحال كل حرب بها يعني كثير من
الانحرافات الحرب هي اساسا يعني تعبير غير
غير جيد
للخلافات او للصراعات وهي اعلى مراتب
الانتهاكات يعني هناك قتل الذين ينظرون
للانتهاكات باعتبارها فقط دخول البيوت
عليه ما ينظر ايضا الى ان هناك انتهاكات
تستهدف ارواح الناس واعتقد ان ارواح الناس
اغلى من البيوت واغلى من السيارات واغلى
من دخول المستشفيات هذا جانب الجانب الاخر
لا اتصور ان هناك حربا تدور في منطقه ولا
يتاثر بها المدنيون هذا امر يعني بطبيعه
المعروف وبالتالي ينبغي عدم الهروب من
المشكله الاساسيه ومناقشه تداعياتها او
نناقشه يعني يعني ما تسببت فيه الحرب
تسببت في ازمات كثيره جدا تسببت فيه ازمه
انسانيه وازمه كذلك صحيه وازمه
غياب وشبح الخدمات والنزوح واللجوء لكن
عندما تريد ان تتحدث او تناقش هذه الازمه
لا تناقش الحرب نفسها يعني تتحدث عن
الاجنده التي وراء الحرب يعني كلنا نعلم
نعلم
انصار النظام البائده انخرطوا في هذا
الصراع قبل مده حتى قبل اعلان التعبئه
العامه ربما تكون هذه هذا الاعلان هو غطاء
لهما الان للمشاركه بشكل علني لكن الاجنده
التي من اجلها تخاذ الحرب حاليا هي اجنده
النظام السابق العوده عن المسار السياسي
الذي كان يجري رفض الاجل الثلاثيه ورفض
الوساطه الدوليه رفض المجتمع الدولي وكذلك
رجل الاتهاماتها للطرفين بعدم تقديم اي
تنازلات هذا ما يقوله الطرف الامريكي واي
طرف يدخل في الوسط
فيما يتعلق بما نقلته وايضا ما نقله مراسل
الجزيره قال ان قياده سلاح المدرعات
استقبلت عددا من المقاتلين بالفعل
السابقين وايضا حركه المستقبل والاصلاح
للاصلاح والتنميه والتيار الاسلامي العريض
اعلن ايضا ترحيبهما بدعوه البرهان بالامس
الى اي حد هذا يعد مؤشر
لنجاح دعوه البرهان في النهايه
انا انا في تقدير المجموعات التي اعلنت
تاييده لهذه الخطوه هي مجموعات معلومه
اتبع تتبع للنظام المؤتمر الوطني
وهي الواجهه السياسيه التي اصبح يتحرك بها
قيادات المؤتمر الوطني من الصف الثاني
والثالث وكذلك حركه الاصلاح الى حد ما
لديها ارتباطات ومصالح وهذا لا ينفي بانه
هنالك عواصم من المؤتمر الوطني يمكن ان
نسميها بالاسماء تشارك وتقاتل في صفوف
والدعم السريع باعتبار ان هذه الحرب حدثت
اصطاف كل طرف يستقروا يحاول ان يدافع في
الطرف الذي يرى من خلال تحقيق مصالحه
وكذلك مكاسبه الشخصيه او ربما الاساريه او
حتى الحزبيه وما الى ذلك فبالنا في تقدير
التقرير الروتر فيه جانب كبير جدا لكن هذا
لا يعني بان الاستجابه كبيره بمعنى ان
الان حتى الان كيف يكون هنالك عناصر وصلت
الى المدرعات تماما ان الاوضاع في الخرطوم
هي الاوضاع عسكريه بحته هنالك انتشار كثيف
لعناصر الدعم السريع في المناطق الجنوبيه
باعتبار ان هذه المنطقه التي منطقه
المدرعه تقصد فيها متاخمه
لمركز قوات الاحتياط المركزي الذي يسيطر
عليه قوات الدعم السري فضلا عن ذلك هنالك
عدد من الارتكازات التي تنتشر في شوارع
الخرطوم فبالتالي انا في تقدير هذه
الجزيره بها العديد من علامات الاستفهام
ربما هي قطاع لمشاركه بعض العناصر حتى
هنالك بعض التقارير والاحاديث لم نتاكد من
صحتها بان مركز المدرعات او قياده
المدرعات اعاده كبير جدا للعناصر
اذا سمحت لي اريد ان اسالك المزمل ابو
القاسم ما هي رهانات الجيش في الفتره
القادمه خصوصا ان ليس هناك اي مؤشر للحسم
والاوضاع الانسانيه على ما هي عليه
اذا كان
الدعم السريع الذي استعان بمجموعات من
المرتزقه القادمه من دول
مجاوره في حربه ضد الشعب السوداني والعقل
ضد الجيش السوداني فما الذي يمنع الجيش
السوداني من ان يستنصر باهله وبشعبه انا
لا استطيع ان افهم حديث الاخوه في
في الاستوديو واخرين عن الاستعانه الجيش
الاسلاميين وغيره انا لا اعرف مؤسسه
سودانيه اوفر انتماء واكثر
ولوغا في العلاقه مع الحركه الاسلاميه من
الدعم السريع الدعم السريع ولد من الحركه
الاسلاميه الجيش الان وماذا يعول عليه في
ظل الوضع الانساني الكارثي الذي تمر به
البلاد يعوي على نفسه وعلى قوته وعلى
العقيدته القتاليه على شعبه كي يضحك هذه
المحاوله التي تستهدف القضاء على بنيه
الدوله السودانيه
حافظ السيد حافظ كبير باختصار شديد يعني
اذا كانت الخارجيه الامريكيه تدعو الطرفين
الى اثبات جديتهما ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمها
او يقدمه الدعم السريع في هذا الاتجاه
يعني الدعم السريع يرحب بالمبادرات كلها
وشارك بفعاليه في منبر جده لكن الطرف الذي
يمانع دائما من التفاوض ويرى بان التفاوض
ينبغي ان يكون حول القضاء الانسانيه وانه
ماضي في خطته للقضاء او على انهاء ما
يعتبره تمرد هو الجيش وبالتالي ليس لديه
ما يمكن ان ينفذ به هذه الخطه خطط انهاء
التمرد وكل يوم يتكبر خسائر يسقط تسقط
المعسكرات للجيش وبالتالي الذي يعول عليه
والخيار المنطقي هو التفاوض التفاوض على
اجنده مطروحه مسبقا قبل هذا الخلاف اجنده
الاصلاح الامن والعسكري وكذلك اجنده
الانتقال السياسي من الحكم الاستبدادي
العسكري الى الحكم المدني الديمقراطي الذي
تشارك فيه قوه الثوره وقوه اخرى بالتالي
نخرج تماما من مساله علاقه الجيش بالسياسه
وعلاقه الجيش بالسلطه التاريخيه التي
اعاقت مسار الانتقال وبالتالي هذا هو
المطروح اذا قبل الجيش بهذا الامر وبهذا
الامر تشجع وتدعمه القوى السياسيه المدنيه
المختلفه كذلك قوه اخرى دوليه تريد هذا
المسار ان يتحققوها
الهدف الثوره الكبير
اذا وسط كل هذه الظروف وايضا دخول عبد
العزيز الحلو وتوسع القتال والكارثه
الانسانيه كيف ترى المخرج
المخرج الان في ظل تعقيد المشهد السياسي
ينبغي ان تكون هنالك ادوار فاعله
وادوار استطيع ان اقول انها حاسمه
وهذا في تقدير هنالك بعض العيوب اذا
استطاعوا ان يعالجها كقضيه توفير مقرات
لقوات الدعم السريعه المنتشره في الاحياء
وكذلك في المستشفيات الى مناطق فضلا عن
ذلك ان تكون هنالك خطه سريعه لدمج عناصر
الدعم السريع في القوات المسلحه فضلا عن
ذلك ان يتم طرح مبدا التنحي بشكل مباشر
ويتم ابعاد قياده المؤسسه العسكريه وكذلك
قوات الدعم السريع واخذنا عن ذلك ان تكون
هنالك فتره الانتقاليه محدوده من كفاءات
وطنيه تجري من خلالها انتخابات تشريعيه
يتم من خلال الانتخاب برلمان هذا البرلمان
يناقش كل التعقيدات الدستوريه ووضع
الدستور ده يمكن كذلك الاصلاح واجراء
اصلاحات في المنظومه القانونيه ومن بعد
تقدير يمكن ان تكون هنالك انتخاب شامله
تخرج البلاد من هذه الازمه لكن بعد ذلك
انا في تقدير المشهد المعقد باعتبار
المؤمنين قبل القوات المسلحه ترغب في بعض
تعقيد المشهد واشكرك جزيلا الكاتب والباحث
السياسي محمد تورشين من باريس وشكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من الدوحه مزمل ابو القاسم ومن
الخرطوم حافظ كبير شكرا لكم جميعا على
متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج مراد الخبر
الى ان نلتقي
[موسيقى]